[Música]
salude y todas las noticias que a ellos
respectan con mi compañera Marc Romero
sala mar Buen día para usted Buenos días
Ángela Bueno este sábado es el Día
Mundial de contra el cáncer y Qué
sabemos del origen de esta enfermedad si
vamos a hacer un repaso desde los
orígenes de esta enfermedad hasta hoy en
día y para eso empezamos con el primer
caso de cáncer de la historia se
descubrió en el pie izquierdo en el
hueso de un pie izquierdo de uno
homínido se descubrió en 2016 que vivió
entre hace 1,8 y 1,6 millones de años
cómo se pudo saber porque este hueso
tenía osteosarcoma que es un cáncer
agresivo de los huesos que de forma pues
las este Hueso y eso se pudo ver
entonces se pudo hacer el diagnóstico
gracias a las técnicas avanzadas que ya
existían en 2016 es muy interesante ver
esto porque desafiaba un poco la idea
del cáncer como una enfermedad
únicamente moderna la verdad es que ha
estado con nosotros desde el inicio de
los tiempos lo que ha sucedido es que
con el envejecimiento de la población
cambios en los hábitos alimenticios de
exposición a riesgos haya sido cada vez
más prevalente pero gracias a esto vemos
que hace ya millones de años el cáncer
estaba entre nosotros Claro pero la
exposición cada vez es mayor ahora cuál
es la primera referencia escrita que
tenemos de esta enfermedad Sí
adelantamos un poco en el tiempo vamos a
2.600 antes de Cristo en uno papiro
escrito por el Egipto y motep ese se
llama el papiro de Edwin samid y habla
de una masa desde el que ven aquí detrás
se habla de una masa en el seno que se
resiste a cualquier tipo de terapia y
habla de hecho de que a veces lo
intentaban extirpar si podían hacerlo
posteriormente el griego hipócrates de
400 antes de Cristo fue quien le dio el
origen de la palabra cáncer porque lo
veía como si fuera una cangrejo por eso
se confunde también a veces con esto
carquinos en griego significa cangrejo y
pues como lo veía en la metástasis eso
fue lo que le di el origen a la palabra
de hecho lo atribuía a una enfermedad
atribuye a la enfermedad desequilibrio
de los fluidos del cuerpo Algo que
claramente hoy en día vemos que no es
así pero si damos un salto adelante en
la historia hay un manuscrito muy
interesante del siglo X escrito por
imsina que se conoce como avicena en el
mundo occidental en el Pues en el
Imperio persa donde describía por
ejemplo eso un cáncer de seno de una
paciente que se había curado por cirugía
y que luego el otro seno también
desarrolló cáncer Entonces es la primera
descripción escrita que tenemos por
ejemplo de una metástasis sin embargo la
comprensión de los procesos Pues
fisiológicos que llevan al cáncer
todavía estaban muy lejos todo lo que
sabemos hoy lo debemos a años y años de
investigación usted nos lo está
mostrando Cómo se determinaron además
las causas del cáncer Pues mira en el
siglo XVII se llegó a pensar que era
contagioso porque afectaba a varias
personas de una misma familia algo que
en realidad hoy en día nos habla de los
Pues de las causas genéticas no del
cáncer pero es luego ya en el siglo 18
19 que se ponen los tumores debajo de un
microscopio por primera vez y se
empiezan a comprender cómo funcionan
estos mecanismos de reproducción
descontrolada celular que es al final el
origen del cáncer luego además empiezan
a entender ya las causas por ejemplo con
la exposición de los trabajadores al
carbón o al hollín de las chimeneas
empieza a entender que este humo también
está asociado con la aparición del
cáncer esto luego se relaciona con el
tabaco que es uno de los principales
causantes de cáncer todavía hoy en día y
se empiezan a aislar también algunos de
los virus como el virus del papiloma
humano que también sabemos que que
provocan el cáncer Entonces tenemos que
eso saltar hasta el siglo XX para
entender pues a cómo es que se despierta
esta enfermedad y ya después empieza a
llegar la innovación en el tema de los
tratamientos con la enfermedad sí los
tratamientos son múltiples No desde la
cirugía que vemos que se practicaba
desde hace pues centenares de años pero
nos vamos a centrar en la historia de la
quimioterapia que es uno de los
tratamientos que más revolucionó la
supervivencia al cáncer en el siglo 20 y
para hacer eso tenemos que ir a 1943 en
Bari Italia en la Segunda Guerra Mundial
cuando los alemanes bombardearon esta
población italiana y allí en el puerto
había barcos con toneladas de gas
mostaza eran el cargamentos secretos que
al bombardearse la ciudad se hundieron
los barcos y hizo hizo que toda la
población quedara expuesta a este agente
químico que se usa que se usó sobre todo
en la Primera Guerra Mundial entonces
científicos de Estados Unidos fueron a
ver cuál había sido las consecuencias de
esta exposición al gas mostaza de todo
ese pueblo y descubrieron en autopsias y
en investigación de los supervivientes
que tenían conteos extremadamente bajos
de glóbulos blancos y ahí surgió la idea
los glóbulos blancos se reproducen
extrañamente rápido muy parecido a veces
a Cómo se reproducen las células
cancerígenas vieron que si el gas
mostaza había parado la reproducción de
estas células quizás podían hacer lo
mismo para frenar el avance del cáncer y
de los tumores Y así fue gracias a una
terrible error y a un terrible accidente
la guerra de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
Cómo se empezó a descubrir que estos
agentes químicos podían tener influencia
en Cómo combatimos el cáncer y cómo se
reproduce conocimiento que es un tesoro
y que lo sigue siendo hasta el presente
Cuáles son los últimos avances contra el
cáncer pues cada año hay nuevos avances
que como decía se construyen sobre
décadas y milenios incluso de
investigación no por ejemplo los avances
en vacunas de ARN mensajero que se
usaron contra el covid y que tienen muy
buenos pronósticos contra el cáncer las
biopsias líquidas nuevas formas de
diagnósticos que hacen que todo esto
cada vez sea una enfermedad con más
supervivencia afecta muchos millones de
personas pero cada vez se sobrevive más
vamos simplemente a destacar uno el
nuevo fármaco que Se generó en 2022 se
llamaba homomix y es una un fármaco
desarrollado por el instituto de
oncología valdebron de Barcelona para
que se reproduzcan las células se
necesitan que la proteína mic y la Max
se junten lleguen al ADN y así se
reproducen las células cancerígenas sin
embargo con este fármaco se evitaba esta
que estas dos proteínas se junten y se
llegó a frenar la metástasis en
muchísimos cánceres digo muy buenos
resultados en animales y este mismo año
2023 van a empezar las pruebas en
humanos Yo diría que esto es una
invitación a reconocer y a valorar los
avances de la ciencia que protegen
nuestras vidas Así es Y también todo
este tiempo que se le dedica y a este
esfuerzo de tantas gentes Pues que sea
un homenaje y gracias a usted gracias
Ángela